to you obviously you've had to study Lee
Harvey Oswald who is he to you what kind
of a person was he you know we've we've
Read All About It we've seen his you
know inspiration his wife his you know
what he was linked to we heard what he
did to different folks who is Lee Harvey
Oswald to you well Lee Harvey Oswald I
believe is probably the most complex 24
year old that probably anybody has ever
studied I mean I mean he he this is a
guy who's has so many facets to him so
many unusual moves to his life okay that
even though we only lived to 24 people
have written books about him all right
in my opinion I believe that Lee Harvey
Oswald uh was recruited into
intelligence work at a relatively young
age I mean how many marines
study the Russian language okay uh how
many how how many marines then get a
hardship discharge six months before
they're supposed to be regularly
discharged then go ahead and travel into
Europe and then the Soviet Union and try
to bargain with them about selling them
secrets to the YouTube plane and then
get shipped 400 miles out of Moscow to
mince because the KGB thinks he's just
fine all right then he comes back home
and now listen to this carefully
we're supposed to believe Oswald is a
Marxist right
who does he live with first the White
Russian Community who want to overthrow
Khrushchev and bring back the Tsar all
right and then where does he go next to
New Orleans
Cuban Exiles who want to overthrow
Castro and bring back Batista what what
kind of a communist does that kind of
stuff all right and then he goes back to
Dallas and he's so oh so lucky to get
this job at the Texas School Book
Depository which just happens to be the
building that the that the parade is
going to take a right turn in front of
so I I the secrets of Lee Harvey Oswald
are still coming out yeah all right
um do I have a couple minutes to explain
a very interesting thing
they Declassified the work of a woman
named Betsy Wolfe who worked for the
house select committee her job was to
study the CIA file on Oswald
she asked for every divisions Charter I
think there's nine in the CIA all right
she read over every Charter studied it
all right and then she did an imaginary
graph this is what Oswald's files should
have done at the CIA okay and then she
goes okay I'm ready for the file she
studies the file guess what Patrick it
didn't do that it didn't do anything
like that all right
his files should have gone to what we
call the SR division Soviet Russia
they didn't go there they went to some
place called the office of security
why is that significant the office of
security does not set up a 201 file all
right which that was the most common
file in the whole CIA all right and
everybody had access to it so she
started interviewing people
and she finally found a guy uh who was
running the Robert Gambino who's running
the office of security at that time and
this is what he said he said look it
doesn't matter how many documents come
in it doesn't matter how they're
pre-stamped
if the client goes to a place called the
office of mail Logistics
they will only send his files to that
department
what this means is that somebody was
rigging Oswald's file in the CIA in 1959
as he's going to the Soviet Union
why would you do that
it was so unusual that those memos if
you can believe this those memos didn't
get printed in the hsca volumes all
right and in fact her work is all hand
written in other words it never got
typed in the memorandum form the only
reason we know about it is because the
ARB put what they called the delayed
release number on her memoranda what
that means is they they figure that this
can be Declassified in say 2004 and this
was the classroom in 2005. that's how
Secret
the life and career of Lee Harvey Oswald
is so with all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future look spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]